what's the first
program you've ever written
oh i have no idea what the first one was
i mean i i know the first machine that i
learned that i learned to program on
what is it was a
a pdp-8
um at the university of calgary
do you remember the specs oh yeah so
so the thing had 4k of ram
nice 12-bit words
the clock rate was um
it was about a third of a megahertz
oh so i didn't even get to the to the m
okay yeah
yeah so you know we're we're like
10 000 times faster these days
um and was this kind of like a super
computer like a serious computer
for no the pdp 8i was the
the first thing that people were calling
like mini computer
got it they were sort of inexpensive
enough that
that a university lab could maybe afford
to buy one
and was there time sharing all that kind
of stuff um there there actually was a
time
sharing os for that but
it wasn't used really widely
the machine that i learned on was one
that was
kind of hidden in the back corner
of the of the computer center
um and it was
it was bought as a as part of a
um project to do computer networking
um but
you know they didn't actually use it
very much it was mostly just kind of
sitting there
and it was kind of sitting there and i
noticed it was just kind of sitting
there and
so i started fooling around with it and
nobody seemed to mind so i just kept
doing that
and i had a keyboard and like a monitor
oh this is way before monitors were
common
so it was it was literally a model 33
teletype
okay with a paper tape reader
okay so the user interface wasn't very
good yeah
yeah it was it was the first computer
ever
built with integrated circuits
but by integrated circuits i mean that
they would have like
10 or 12 transistors on one piece of
silicon
not the 10 or 12 billion
that machines have today
so what did that i mean feel like if you
remember those
i mean did you have kind of inklings of
the
the magic of exponential kind of
improvement of moore's law
of the potential of the future that was
at your fingertips kind of thing oh
it's just a cool yeah it was just a toy
you know i'd always like building stuff
but one of the problems with building
stuff is that you need to have
parts you know you need to have pieces
of wood or
wire or switches or stuff like that
and those all cost money and here you
could build
you could build arbitrarily complicated
things and i didn't need
any physical materials um
it required no money that's right it's a
good way to put programming you're right
it's uh
if you love building things it uh okay
so it
you know completely accessible you don't
need anything
and anybody from anywhere could just
build something really cool yeah
yeah if you've got access to a computer
you can you can build
all kinds of crazy stuff um
and you know and
when you were somebody like
me who had like really no money
um and i mean i
i remember just lusting after being able
to buy like
a transistor
um you know and when i would do
sort of electronics kind of projects
they were mostly made
done by like dumpster diving for trash
you know and you know one of my big
hauls was
uh discarded relay racks from the back
of a
the phone company switching center oh
nice
that was the big memorable treasure oh
yeah yeah
that was what do you use that for i i
built a machine that played tic-tac-toe
nice out of relays of course the thing
that was really hard
um was that all the relays required a
specific voltage
but getting a power supply that will
would
do that voltage was pretty hard and
since i had a bunch of trashed
television sets i had to
um sort of cobble together
something that was wrong but worked
um so i was actually running these
relays at 300 volts
and and none of the electrical
connections were like
properly sealed off surprised you
survived that period of your life
oh for so many reasons for so many
reasons
i mean you know you're you know it's
pretty common for teenage geeks to
discover
oh thermite that's real easy to make
yeah well i'm glad you did but do you
remember the
do you remember what program in calgary
that you wrote anything that stands out
and what language
well so mostly the
anything of any size was
assembly code um
and actually before i learned assembly
code there was this programming language
on the pdb8 called focal 5
and vocal 5 was kind of like a really
stripped down
fortran and
i remember playing you know building
programs that did things like
play blackjack
[Music]
or solitaire or for some reason or the
things that
i really liked were ones where they were
just like plot plotting graphs
so something with uh like a function or
a data
and then you plot it yeah
yeah i did the bunches of those things
and went ooh
pretty pictures um and so this would
like print out
again no no monitors right so it was
like
on a teletype yeah
so it's using something that's kind of
like a
a typewriter and then using those
to plot functions
you